are you looking for an excuse to play  more fallout 4 DLC is about the best  reason you can have and now we know  exactly when the first pack is launching  I'm Tony and this is your robotic  gamespot news updates fallout 4 is  automaton DLC pack hits ps4 xbox one and  pc on march twenty second with a ten  dollar price tag the dlc focuses on the  evil mechanist in the army of robots he  unleashes across the Commonwealth you  can hunt down those robots harvest their  parts and create your own Robo buddy to  aid you in combat and of course there  are new quests achievements weapons  abilities and armor pieces to automaton  launches this month and two more  expansions are planned for April in May  wasteland workshop will add the ability  to craft animal cages and far harbour  will be the biggest expansion Bethesda  has ever done to keep up with all the  fallout 4 news stay tuned to gamespot  there's even more promised for 2016